ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES RUN DOWN.
PORGES BRAD CABALLERO CHANGE.
DALLY DODD THE RAZA I. CAN
GROSS HERTZBERG HELLO HUESO
HURTADO JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ MITCHELL MORNING
MORLOCK MORALE. NIELSEN PAN
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN NUMBER MY CASKEY WIENER
WELL. CORMS PRESENT MEMBERS
TODAY WE HAVE SENATOR GLAZERS
AND CENTER JACKSON
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY SO I
WANT TO WELCOME THOSE SENATORS.
IN FACT ACCORDING TO WIKIPEDIA
TODAY IS SENATOR GLAZERS SIXTY
THIRD BIRTHDAY SO HAPPY
BIRTHDAY CENTER GLAZER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
MARSHALLESE NOT SIXTY FOUR
BECAUSE IT IS GOING TO HAVE TO
SING THE BEATLES SONG SO. EDDIE
OKAY THE CENTER WOULD BE- WILL
PARTICIPATE IN DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE BUT WILL NOT BE
PARTICIPATING IN THE QUORUM
CALL OR ON THE VOTE ON MEASURES.
AT THIS TIME IT WOULD MEMBERS
ENTER GAS BEYOND THE REALM IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYERS AFTERNOON
SENATOR ALAN. AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
BY THE GREAT SENATOR FROM NAPA
COUNTY SENATOR DIED. THIS IS
THE PRAYER OF ANY HILL ASSUME
FROM HER DIARIES OF NINETEEN
FORTY ONE NINETEEN FORTY THREE.
HE WAS KILLED IN AUSCHWITZ ON
NOVEMBER THIRTIETH NINETEEN
FORTY THREE. DEAR GOD THESE ARE
ANXIOUS TIMES. TONIGHT FOR THE
FIRST TIME I LAY IN THE DARK
WITH BURNING EYES AS SEEN AFTER
SEEN OF HUMAN SUFFERING PASSED
BEFORE ME. I SAW PROMISE YOU
ONE THING THAT. JUST ONE VERY
SMALL THING I SHALL NEVER
BURDEN MIGHT TODAY WITH CARES
ABOUT MY TOMORROW ALTHOUGH THAT
TAKES SOME PRACTICE. EACH DAY
SUFFICIENT TO ITSELF. I SHALL
TRY TO HELP YOU GUIDE TO STOP
MY STRENGTH EBBING AWAY
ALTHOUGH I CANNOT VOUCH FOR IT
IN ADVANCE. BUT ONE THING IS
BECOMING INCREASINGLY CLEAR TO
ME. THAT YOU CANNOT HELP US. WE
MUST HELP YOU TO HELP OURSELVES.
AND THAT IS ALL WE CAN MANAGE
THESE DAYS AND ALSO ALL THAT
REALLY MATTERS THAT WE
SAFEGUARD THAT LITTLE PIECE OF
YOU'VE GOTTEN OURSELVES AND
PERHAPS IN OTHERS AS WELL. ALAS
THERE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE MUCH
YOU YOURSELF CAN DO ABOUT OUR
CIRCUMSTANCES ABOUT OUR LIVES.
NEITHER DO I HOLD YOU
RESPONSIBLE. YOU CANNOT HELP US
BUT WE MUST HELP YOU AND DEFEND
YOUR DWELLING PLACE INSIDE US
TO THE LAST. MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN PLACE FOR FLAG.
RELATED TO THE- FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. AND
TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. UNDER GOD. STRONG. ALL
RIGHTS ARE CENTERS MOVING ON
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MOVING
NOW TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. UP SENATOR DOLE. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I MOVED JOINT
RULE SIXTY TWO AB WAIVERS FOR
THE LABOR AND PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE HERE
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWO THREE
ON TUESDAY AUGUST ELEVENTH
TWENTY TWENTY WITHOUT FOUR DAYS
NOTICE IN THE DAILY FILE THANK
YOU CENTER HILL SENATOR JONES.
ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM CENTER HILL TO. WAY THE
RULES AND SO HE'S ASKING FOR A
NIGHT. WHO'S THAT WHICH ONES BY.
RESEARCHERS OBJECTED SO YEAH
YEAH SO SIR HILL SEVEN FOR THE
IPHONE X. CENTER JONES THE NO
VOTE. CLERK PLEASE CALL MEMBERS.
ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS
AYE BATES. TELL FIVE BARGES NO
BRADFORD I CUT BY ADAM I CHIANG.
DALLY NO DODD. HI THE RISER HI
CAL JOHNNY. GONZALEZ I GROW I.
HERTZBERG. HI HILL AYE HUESO.
HURTADO. JONES NO LEYVA. FIVE
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL.
I MONNING HI MORLOCK NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN. PAN FIVE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH. HI RUBIO. I SKINNER.
STERN NUMBER I LIKE HOUSEKI
FIVE WIENER AYE WILK. CLARK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FACE. CHIANG GALGIANI. GROSS
HUESO. HURTADO. NIELSEN SKINNER.
STERN WILK. VICE TWENTY TWO NO
SIX THE RULE WAIVER IS
SUSPENDED. YEAH JOINT RULES ARE
SUFFICIENT. CONTINUING UNDER A
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION FILE ITEM%
NUMBER TWO WILL BE STRICKEN
FROM THE FILE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNALS
FROM AUGUST THIRD THROUGH
AUGUST EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED
BY THE MINUTE CLERK. GO WAY IN
THE BACK SENATOR DELHI. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT PERCENT TWO
SENATE RULE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT
I AM MAKING A MOTION TO
WITHDRAW AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR FROM THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SO THAT THE FULL SENATE CAN
HAVE A FIGURES TO ABOUT THE
MERITS OF COBIT LIABILITY
EXEMPTION PROTECTIONS FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS EXPECTING
EXPRESSLY RULE WANTS TO BE ABLE
TO RE OPEN IMMEDIATELY. THANK
YOU CENTER DALLY MAJORITY
LEADER. JORDAN RESTAURANT NO
VOTE. SENATOR JONES THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I RISE IN FAVOR OF
THE MOTION AND ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT TO CENTER
DOLLARS ASPIRIN AYE AYE VOTE.
CONSIDER HERTZBERG AND A NO
VOTE CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN NO ARCHULETA NO ATKINS NO
BABIES. BELL NO PORGES I BRAD.
BRADFORD NO BY ADAM. NO. CHIANG.
I DALLY HI I DON. NO THE RYZEN
NO GALGIANI. GONZALEZ NO GROWTH.
HERTZBERG NO HILL NO WAY SO
HURTADO NO JONES I LEYVA. NO
MITCHELL. MONEY NO MORE LOCK. I
HELLO HI NIELSEN. PAN NO
PORTANTINO. NO ROCK. NO RUBIO.
SKINNER STERN. AMBERG I DON'T
KNOW WHAT HOUSEKI NO WIENER. NO
WILK HI HI CLERK PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES
GALGIANI. GROVE. HUESO MITCHELL.
NIELSEN PREVIA NO SKINNER STERN.
HIS EIGHT NOS TWENTY TWO MOTION
FAILS. CENTER DOLLY THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT AT APPROPRIATE
TIME I WOULD LIKE TO BE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK ON
CONDITION OF THE FILE. THANK
YOU SIR AND WE WILL DO THAT NOW.
FIRST F A REMOVED A
GUBERNATORIAL GUBERNATORIAL
APPOINTMENTS SO WE HAVE A ITEMS
ONE AND ITEMS NUMBER THREE SO
FOR THAT WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO
THE PRO TEN. PERCY WHEN YOU
CARE TO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- I WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT ON ITEM NUMBER ONE FILE
ITEM ONE IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
ALBERT JOHNSON IS THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY
PRIOR TO THIS APPOINTMENT MR
JOHNSON WAS DIRECTOR OF INTER
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS FOR THE
SAN MANUEL BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS. HE ALSO PREVIOUSLY
SERVED AS CHIEF CONSULTANT FOR
THE ASSEMBLY GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE HE WAS
APPROVED BY OUR SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JUNE THIRD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
BUT- IS THERE SOMEBODY OUT.
RIGHT I'M SORRY CENTER HEN DO
NOT SEE I APOLOGIZE CENTER
CHIANG. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I DON'T USUALLY SPEAK
AGAINST APPOINTMENTS AND I
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT CANDIDATES WHEN THE
PERSON IS QUALIFIED I RESPECT
THE PRIVILEGE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IN THIS PROCESS AND
BELIEVE A ROLE AS A CO EQUAL
BRANCH SHOULD BE CAUTIOUS IN
TYING UP APPOINTMENTS. THE
COLLEAGUES I CANNOT SUPPORT
THIS PARTICULAR APPOINTMENT.
LAST YEAR AFTER REVIEWING THE
REVENUE NUMBERS AT THE STATE
LOTTERY AND THEIR ALLOCATION TO
SCHOOLS IT BECAME CLEAR TO ME
THAT THE NUMBERS DID NOT ADD
UP. REVENUE SKYROCKETED FOR THE
LOTTERY TO STORABLE LEVELS BUT
REVENUE TO SCHOOLS REMAIN FLAT.
I WORK WITH THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE TO
DIRECT THE STATE AUDITOR TO
LOOK INTO THIS ISSUE. IT TURNS
OUT THERE ARE SERIOUS ISSUES IN
VARIOUS PROGRAMS AND PROTOCOLS.
AND I THE TIME TO OUTLINE OF
THOSE. BUT IT BECAME VERY CLEAR
THAT THE LOTTERY OWES OUR
STUDENTS AT LEAST THIRTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS. THAT'S MONEY
FOR SUPPLIES TEACHERS. AND
TECHNOLOGY IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS SHORTCHANGED BY THE
LOTTERY. INSTEAD OF RECOGNIZING
WHAT THE STATE AUDITOR AND
COVERED IN PAYING BACK OUR
SCHOOLS. STATE LOTTERY
ATTORNEYS UNDER MISTER
JOHNSON'S LEADERSHIP FOUND
EXCUSES. AND KEPT THE MONEY AND
THEN TURNED AROUND AND HEARD
EVEN MORE STAFF ATTORNEYS AND
IN HOUSE OTHER PROFESSIONALS.
AND OUR SCHOOLS WILL SEE THOSE
FUNDS. AND THEY WILL CONTINUE
TO GET SHORT CHANGED UNTIL
THERE ARE SERIOUS CHANGES. I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF
THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION ON THIS
APPOINTMENT AND SOME MEMBERS
DID ACKNOWLEDGE. THAT CHANGES
MIGHT NEED TO BE MADE. I LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT CONVERSATION
AND WORK. I UNDERSTAND MR
JOHNSON HAS A LONG RESPECTABLE
CAREER BEFORE HIS TIME AT THE
LOTTERY AND HE WILL LOOK TO
THAT AS YOU CAST YOUR VOTE. I
CAN KNOWLEDGE THAT WOULD BE
THESE. ONES WILL BE LAYING OFF
PLANE TODAY. HE SAID CHANG
CENTER SO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I JUST WANT TO STAND ON VOICE
MY SUPPORT FOR MISTER JOHNSON
WHO AS MY COLLEAGUE SAYS DOES
HAVE A LONG DISTINGUISHED
CAREER ON IN STATE SERVICE IN
THE LEGISLATURE YOU KNOW THE
LOTTERY HAS FOR- A NUMBER OF
YEARS HAD MANY CHALLENGES AND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS ALL
CHALLENGE THEM IN TERMS OF
MAKING SURE THEY ARE DOING.
WHAT'S RIGHT FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE VOTERS IN
TERMS OF DIRECTING AS MUCH
MONEY AS POSSIBLE TO SCHOOLS
ARE THINGS TO JOHNSON IN HIS
NEW LEADERSHIP THERE WILL LEAD
US IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND
DON'T THINK HE SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR OUR
SHORTCOMINGS OF THE LOTTERY
IMPASSE PAPRIKA PASS DIRECTORS
SO I WILL PROBABLY BE CAP ABOUT
IT SUPPORT BUSINESS JOHNSON
CONFIRMATION TODAY. THANK YOU
SIR MITCHELL SO BRAD. THANK YOU
MISS PRESIDENT I TOO WANT TO
STAND IN FRONT SUPPORT OF MR
JOHNSON SOMEONE AND I'M KNOWN
FOR NUMEROUS YEARS HAVE BEEN A-
PROFESSIONAL ALL ASPECTS OF HIS
CAREER INDIVIDUAL WHO'S VERY-
WILLING TO ENGAGE IN. AND IT'S
JUST ACCOUNTABLE AND TOO LATE
IS BURDEN OF THE MISMANAGEMENT
OF THE LOTTERY OR WHATEVER IT'S
PERCEIVED TO BE MISMANAGEMENT
ON HIS- DOOR HAS A NEWLY
APPOINTED. CORRECT I THINK IS
UNFAIR AND WE'VE ALL VOICED
CONCERNS OVER THE YEARS OVER
BELLOTTO SO I THINK MR JOHNSON
THE RIGHT LEADER AT THE RIGHT
TIME TO MOVE. THE CALIFORNIA
LOTTERY IN THAT RIGHT DIRECTION
SUCH STRONG ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR BRADFORD SEEING
NO OTHER. US SENATOR JONES
SEARCH SERVICE PRESIDENT I JUST
WANTED TO- RISE IN AGREEMENT
WITH THAT COMMENTS FROM OUR
CALLING FROM DIAMOND BAR AND
THEN ALSO THE OTHER COMMENTS-
FROM ALL OF OUR. COLLEAGUES
THIS MORNING A KNOWLEDGE IN THE
CHALLENGES WITH THE LAW AND
MAYBE IT'S A TIME FOR THIS
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR TO
THINK ABOUT UNWINDING THE
LOTTERY AND I'M DOING IT AND
CLOSING IT DOWN FOREVER. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU CENTER JONES SEEING
NO OTHER MIKES UP. MATTER PRO
TEM DO YOU WANT TO CLOSE THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I WOULD LIKE
TO. I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUES I WOULD DIRE-
REITERATE A COUPLE OF THINGS
ONE. THERE REALLY WAS A ROBOT
AND EXTENSIVE CONVERSATION OF
THE RULES COMMITTEE. HI AS IT
RELATES TO A NUMBER OF ISSUES I
WOULD SAY. IN TERMS OF THE
DISCUSSION AND THE AUDIT. I
THERE IS A DISPUTE OVER THE
METHODOLOGY OF. HELD TO ACCOUNT
FOR THESE DOLLARS. THAT IS
SOMETHING THE CONTROLLER HAS
BROUGHT UP THAT IS SOMETHING
THE AUDITOR. OBVIOUSLY PUT OUT
THERE IS A NEW STUDY UNDER WAY-
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE ISSUES THAT
WE AS A LEGISLATURE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT. OVERSEE
HOLD ACCOUNTABLE. FIVE AT THE
SAME TIME. I WOULD SAY THAT- MR
JOHNSON IS THE NEW DIRECTOR
BEING APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR. I HE ALSO SPOKE TO A
NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
SEEN DISPLAYED. PUBLICLY ABOUT
THE CULTURE OF- THAT
DEPARTMENT. THE MORALE OF THE
STAFF AND I THINK THAT MR
JOHNSON ACTUALLY- RESPONDED
QUITE WELL TO THOSE COMMENTS
THE CONCERNS AND WHILE I.
UNDERSTAND THE VOTE OF MIKE. I
FEEL VERY COMFORTABLE WITH THE
PRESENTATION THAT HE MADE THE-
RESPONSES HE GAVE TO US. AND
THERE MAY BE WORK THAT WE NEED
TO DO IS A LEGISLATOR. I
LEGISLATURE- AS IT RELATES TO
SOME OF THESE ISSUES
PARTICULARLY IF WE GET THE
INFORMATION RELATED TO THE NEW
STUDY. BUT TODAY I WOULD STAND
BY THE- VOTE OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY FOR MISTER JOHNSON.
TAKING THAT APPROACH HIM
WITHOUT A SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES. TELL FIVE FOR
JUST. BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM I
CHIANG. DALLY DODD. BY THE
RESIN FIVE GALGIANI. GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG AYE HILL I
LISTEN HURTADO I JONES. NO
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING HI MORLOCK.
MERLE. NIELSEN NIELSEN. PAN
FIVE PORTANTINO I. ROSS I RUBIO.
HI SKINNER STERN I'M BURKE I
WHAT KASKY I WIENER. I WILK.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES PORGES.
CHIANG DALLY. GALGIANI GROSS.
HUESO MELENDEZ. MORLOCK. ZERO
NIELSEN. SKINNER STERN. WELL.
PRICE TWENTY THREE KNOWS ONE
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE MADAM PRO TEN.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF MISTER DOUGLAS
PARKER AS DIVISION CHIEF FOR
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
AT THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY PRIOR TO
THIS APPOINTMENT MR PARKER
SERVED AS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF WORK SAFE A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION FOCUSED
ON WORKER HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
SUPPORT FOR LEGAL AID PROGRAMS.
SERVING LOW WAGE AND IMMIGRANT
WORKERS HE WAS APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON JUNE
SEVENTEENTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MAYOR PRO TEM. SEE ANY ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
MORLOCK. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT.
I'M JUST CURIOUS OF- THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY OVERSEES THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB FIVE.
PLEASE FOR THOSE THAT HAVEN'T
BEEN CARVED OUT. DO YOU WANT TO
DO A DRESS THAT AT ALL MANNA
PRO TEM WELL THANK YOU ARE.
WELL FROM WHAT I DON'T RECALL
THAT COMING UP AS PART OF THE
CONVERSATION IT RULES BUT HE IS
THE DIVISION CHIEF FOR OSHA
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
SO AS ANYTHING WOULD RELATE I
WOULD THINK IT WOULD MORE BE
THE LABOR- THE HEAD OF THE
LABOR- DIVISION AND DEPARTMENT
THE SECRETARY THAT WOULD
OVERSEE AND DICTATE THAT I.
CAN'T SAY MORE THAN THAT MISTER
PRESIDENT. THANK RISK PRESENT I
WASN'T QUITE SURE MYSELF AND I
JUST THOUGHT I'D ASK THANK YOU.
ERASER MORLOCK. SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE AND THEN
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES.
TELL FIVE GORGEOUS. BRADFORD
FIVE CABRERA I CHIANG. DALLY
DODD. FIVE TERRAZZA HI GALGIANI
GONZALEZ I DROVE. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL I HUESO HER TADO I JONES.
LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ NO
MITCHELL I MONEY HI MORLOCK.
MORALE NO NIELSEN PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH FIVE RUBIO.
HI SKINNER. STERN NUMBER I Y.
CASKEY HI WIENER. I WILK.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. FACE FOR JUST.
CHIANG DALLY. GALGIANI GROVE.
HUESO JONES. MORLOCK NIELSEN.
SKINNER STERN. WILK. HIS TWENTY
THREE KNOWS TO THE APPOINTMENT
IS CONFIRMED. MR DALLEY FOR
WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RISE. UNDER
A CONDITION THE PILE HE MAYES
RECEDE THANK YOU EARLIER I
BROUGHT UP AT THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU-
RULE SCHOOLS SCHOOLS OPEN WOULD
HAVE OPENED LAST WEEK IN A ROW
AREAS OF CALIFORNIA. AND
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
INTERNET THEY CAN'T DISTANCE
LEARN THESE SCHOOLS WOULD BE
ABLE TO HAVE THEIR CHILDREN IN
THOSE SCHOOLS IF THERE WAS A
WAIVER FOR THE LIABILITY. UNDER
CODE THAT'S THE REASON I ASK
FOR THIS BILL TO BE BROUGHT TO
THE FLOOR I RESPECTFULLY- QUEST
THAT THAT WE KIDS. TO LEARNING
MISTER PRESIDENT YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLY WITHOUT MOVING ON
TO COMMITTEE S. COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE
TO INFORM THE SENATORS THAT
WE'RE HAVING A MEETING OF FOR
THE MILITARY VETERANS HEARING.
AT THE TWO FORTY AND THAT WILL
BE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
AT TWO FORTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR CENTER PAN. YEAH.
TRYING TO HELP THERE YOU GO
OKAY I WAS ONE YES THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH WILL BE
HOLDING ITS HEARING AFTER THE
CONCLUSION OF THE VETERANS
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE BUT HERE IN
THE SENATE CHAMBER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR NO THERE'S- A
KNACK IS WELL THEY DO NOT SEE
SENATOR GALGIANI CAN SOMEBODY.
ALL RIGHT QUICK BUZZ. IT'S NOT
A BONTA GERMAN OF AG. VETERANS
IT'S ON A ADJOURNMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS FORTY SO
CULTURE COMMITTEE WILL MEET-
FOLLOWING VETERANS AFFAIR IN
ROOM FORTY TWO THREE. AND NOW
WITH ALL THAT IS THERE NO OTHER
BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS THE DESK
IS CLEAR. MISTER PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD LUCK TO
ALL MY COLLEAGUES THIS WEEK AS
WE CONTINUE THE CRITICAL
BUSINESS OF OUR STATE. THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION WILL BE THIS
THURSDAY AUGUST THIRTEENTH AT
TWENTY OR TWENTY TWENTY AT NINE
AM THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THANK
YOU. TO REPEAT THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL ALL
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESSES RECEIVED
AT THE DESK. AND WE WILL
RECONVENE THIS COMING THURSDAY
AT NINE AM. THANK YOU MEMBERS.